in den usa geht eine neuartige zombie
krankheit um die nervenkrankheit chronik
wasting disease double you die betrifft
bisher vor allem ältere und hirsche in
mindestens 24 us bundesstaaten und die
symptome der erkrankten tiere erinnern
wirklich sehr an zombies sie haben ihren
körper nicht mehr unter kontrolle werden
aggressiv und verlieren ihre angst vor
menschen jetzt schlagen us fachleute
alarm demnach kann wohl nicht mehr
ausgeschlossen werden dass diese zombie
nervenkrankheit auch auf menschen
übertragbar ist eine behandlung oder
impfstoffe gibt es bisher nicht sind wir
wehrlos ausgeliefert kriegs um science
fiction die gibt's täglich spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal nur
dann verpasst ihr nichts herzlich
willkommen
[Musik]
und vielen dank für diesen
themenvorschlag denen sich wirklich
wahnsinnig viele von euch über unsere
whatsapp community gewünscht haben den
link gibt es in der infobox und am ende
des videos die lage in den usa ist laut
der us bundesbürger center of disease
control and prevention cdc angespannt
die fachleute dort beschäftigen sich mit
ansteckenden krankheiten und haben jetzt
eine alarmierende warnung herausgegeben
es geht um die sogenannte chronic
wasting dc szenario die auch als zombie
hirsch krankheit bezeichnet und diesen
namen trägt sie völlig zu recht denn die
erkrankten tiere erinnern tatsächlich an
untote sie nähmen stark ab haben ihren
körper kommen noch unter kontrolle und
sabbern zudem verlieren sie ihre angst
vor menschen und werden dafür immer
aggressiver vergleichbar ist sie dabei
auch mit rinderwahn bse und scrapie
schaffen denn auch hierbei handelt es
sich um eine ansteckende
prionenerkrankung diese entstehen wenn
sich ein bestimmtes zell
oberflächenprotein im gehirn das
sogenannte prionen protein fehlerhaft
faltet die krankheit greift also das
zentrale nervensystem an übertragen wird
die zombie krankheit wohl über blut urin
speichel oder kot klar ist jedenfalls
dass ich sie damit die gerade rasant in
den usa ausbreitet bislang sind nur
tiere wie elche und hirsche unter den
opfern das jedoch in mindestens 24 us
staaten und in zwei kanadischen
provinzen fälle in denen sie dabei die
auch auf haustiere oder gar menschen
übertragen
wir sind bisher nicht bekannt das gilt
bisher auch als eher unwahrscheinlich
doch das hat sich jetzt wohl geändert
mittlerweile kann wohl nicht mehr
ausgeschlossen werden dass sich die
krankheit auch auf menschen übertragen
könnte davor warnt jetzt zumindest der
us forscher michael osterholz der als
experte für infektionskrankheiten gilt
zitat es ist wahrscheinlich dass fälle
von stabilo die beim menschen in den
kommenden jahren dokumentiert werden die
mit dem verzehr von kontaminiertem
fleisch in verbindung stehen das ist
derzeit noch keine beweise für
infektionen beim menschen gibt liegt
seiner ansicht nach an dem verzögerten
auftreten der krankheit dazu der
wissenschaftler
wir können nicht auf die ersten fälle
warten auch die us-behörde cdc ordnete
die krankheit als ernsthafte bedrohung
an auf der webseite heißt es bislang hat
es keine fälle einer familie die
infektion beim menschen gegeben einige
studien an tieren legen jedoch nahe
das ist ein risiko für bestimmte nicht
menschlichen primaten beispielsweise
affen gibt die in kontakt mit
körperflüssigkeiten von infizierten
reden oder elchen kommen oder das
fleisch von denjenigen tieren essen dem
interview die infiziert sind die studien
deuten demnach aber darauf hin dass auch
menschen gefährdet sein könnten das
deutsche friedrich loeffler institut
schrieb dazu 2016 auf seiner webseite
derzeit kann eine übertragung auf den
menschen nicht gänzlich ausgeschlossen
werden
dennoch scheint diese gefahr ähnlich wie
bei scrapie sehr gering zu sein
demnach legen studien nahe dass es eine
erhebliche spezies barriere bei der
übertragung von zieht damit auf menschen
gibt erste fälle von ziel dabei wurden
übrigens schon 1967 bekannt und zwar bei
maultaschen in colorado
seitdem wurde die krankheit aus südkorea
mindestens 24 us staaten und zwei
kanadischen provinzen gemeldet
im april 2016 dann das erste mal
außerhalb von nordamerika und südkorea
und zwar in europa bei einem rentier in
norwegen und so beobachtet man die
erkrankung dort ganz genau
mittlerweile wurde sie dabei die bei 19
rentieren 4 elchen und einem rot in
norwegen festgestellt und deswegen mehr
als 1400 rentiere allein in der region
nord keller erschossen
mehr als 70.000 tiere wurden untersucht
dazu das norwegische
landwirtschaftsministerium norwegen hat
große anstrengungen unternommen um
ziehen damit die aus zu merzen aber wir
wissen nicht ob wir es schon geschafft
haben ausgeschlossen werden kann
keinesfalls das ziel die auch nach
deutschland gelangt möglich ist dies zum
einen über den natürlichen weg also über
tiere die eingeschleppt werden aber auch
urlauber oder jäger könnten dazu
beitragen dass die krankheit auch bei
uns auftritt klar ist aber um den kampf
gegen die krankheit wirklich aufzunehmen
muss wohl noch jahr lang intensiv
geforscht werden zum derzeitigen
zeitpunkt haben wir jedenfalls nichts
gegen die krankheit in der hand weder
medizinische behandlung noch impfung
aktuell nachzügler nidda südosten
afrikas tod cholera-epidemie
draufklicken und anschauen denn da sieht
man gut wie schnell epidemien außer
kontrolle geraten ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran